I think in part because clustering tends not to have one
consistent definition it's very algorithm
driven. So there's different algorithms for
doing clustering and we can analyze each of those algorithms somewhat
independently. There isn't really one problem and then there's a bunch
of different algorithms for attacking that one problem. Each algorithm kind
of has its own problem. So, I think the, the easiest
way to go through and talk about unsupervised learning and clustering
is to start going through some algorithms. So I'm going to start with
single linkage clustering, because I think it's
in many ways the simplest and most natural.
>> Okay.
>> And it has some very nice properties. So it's,
it's, it's not a terrible idea, it's been very useful in
statistics in a very long time. So, so here's how
single linkage clustering goes, let's imagine we've got these objects. That
we'll call them these little, these little red dots. We're
imagine that they're objects and just because it would be hard
to write down all the D values between them. Let's
just literally use the 2 dimensional space, the distance on the
slide here as the distances. Okay.
>> Okay.
>> So, you can, so if you were, if you were asked to cluster this
how would you do it? Like, what do you think the, the groupings ought to be?
>> Well, just staring at them they're either two or they're four.
>> Mm.
>> Or maybe, there's five. So, I would
probably put the three on the left that
there together, together. And I would put the
four on the right that are together, together.
Or I might notice that the two at the top of the ones on the right
are more together than the other two and
sub divide them some more. But, if I were
just far enough away, I would definitely say
so that seems like a reasonable clustering, but
also the one that took all four of
those and put them together is a reasonable clustering.
>> Right. Yeah, yeah. That means that sort
of agrees with what my eyes are thinking as
well. Alright, so so it'd be good if we
can recover that kind of structure algorithmically, so let's let's
talk through this, this algorithm. It's
called single linkage clustering, sometimes SLC.
>> Or "slick". nice. It's a, it's
a hierarchical agglomorative cluster of algorithm, or HAC.
>> [LAUGH] I like that acronym even better.
>> That's an Andrew Moore joke, for what it's worth.
>> Oh, it's a slick HAC.
>> Nice. All right. So here's what we're going to
do. We're going to consider each object a cluster to start.
We're going to do this interatively. So we start off
with N objects, like we have here. One, two,
three, four, five, six, seven. And we're going to define
the inter cluster distance as the distance between the closest
two points in the two clusters. So in the
beginning, all the points are in their own clusters.
All the objects are in their own clusters. So
the inter. Cluster distance is exactly the interobject distance. Okay?
>> Okay.
>> But, little by little, we're going to actually
be aggregating things into larger clusters and we have to define what
it means for how, how close is one cluster to another. And
we'll say the close, the closest between two clusters is the closest
of the closest two points between those two clusters. All right. So, so
now what we're going to do is we're going to iterate. We're
going to say merge the two closest clusters, because, you know, they belong
together. And then we're just going to repeat that n minus k
times To leave us with K clusters. So K is now an input
to this algorithm.
>> Okay.
>> All right. So help me out. Let's step through
this. What what would we merge first according to this algorithm?
>> Well, they're either on cluster I, according to
my eyesight, which is, of course, perfect. I would take
the two left most ones, upper left most ones.
Probably and merge them together. They look closest to me.
>> Alright let me label them just to make your life a little bit easier.
>> Oh that'd be nice.
>> Alright. SO what do you think?
>> I would bring
A and B togheter.
>> ALright. They're now a cluster. So we had seven clusters now we
have six. Oh by the way we're trying to get down to two.
>> Okay and then I would put C and D together.
>> Yeah, that's what I was thinking too.
>> Then I would probably want to put c,
d, and e together, because they're in alphabetical order.
>> [LAUGH]. All right, well, just to be concrete about this, why, what is
the next step that we're supposed to do? What we're supposed to do is
say which pair of clusters is closest. And again,
the, the, distance between, say, I don't know, the
a b cluster and the c d cluster is not the average over all the points or the
furthest points but the closest ones. So, like I
think c and d, the,the distance between the a
b cluster and the c d cluster is exactly
the distance between b and d in this case.
>> Mm-hm.
>> Does that make sense?
>> Yeah.
>> Alright. So we know what's the currently closest pair of clusters.
>> from, from where I am looking, it's either e to the c and
d or g to a and b and they look very similar to me.
>> E to C and D or G to B and A, that's what you said?
>> Yeah. Probably G to B and A, staring at.
>> I tried really hard to make it so that they're be
an easy answer, but you're right, I, they're really close. So let's,
let's I think it doesn't matter too much. we'll, we'll say that
that one's neck. So now we'll say, now we'll do a quick quiz.
>> Okay. So what merge
does, single link clustering do next? Just give
the pair of points I would be connecting.
>> Okay.
>> Say, separated by a comma.